Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
Réformer les institutions,
pour quoi faire ?
Quoi qu'on pense
de la réforme des retraites,
elle a cristallisé un malaise
social qui paraît durable.
L'emploi répétitif du 49.3
auparavant et pour cette réforme
a mis
la représentation parlementaire
en ébullition. Au malaise social
s'est ajoutée une crise politique,
mais pas de crise de régime,
parce que la Constitution
de la Ve République a prévu
de pouvoir gouverner
par temps de crise.
Certes, certains en appellent
à une VIe République,
mais sans qu'on discerne
le contenu de leurs revendications
institutionnelles.
Un retour à la IVe République
n'apparaît pas plus convaincant.
Reste la tentation bien française
d'une bougeotte institutionnelle,
alors que les Etats-Unis
n'ont pas changé de constitution
depuis deux siècles et demi.
La France en est
à sa 15e constitution
depuis 1789.
Et la Ve République,
initiée par la réforme
du général de Gaulle en 1958
a fait l'objet
de 24 remaniements.
On prête
à l'actuel président Emmanuel Macron
la volonté politique de remanier
à son tour la Constitution.
Dans quelle direction
et pour en faire quoi ?
Nous allons voir cela
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Marie-Noëlle Lienemann,
vous êtes sénatrice
et vous êtes ancienne ministre.
Dominique Reynié,
vous êtes politologue,
professeur à Sciences Po
et président de Fondapol.
Olivier Passelecq, vous êtes
professeur de droit à l'IPAG de
l'université Paris Panthéon Assas.
Dominique Rousseau,
vous êtes juriste et professeur
de droit constitutionnel.
Vous venez de voir cette citation
de Jean-Louis Bourlanges.
Elle est pleine d'humour.
"Il n'était pas sain de faire
du président à la fin
"le symbole de l'Etat
et le chef du gouvernement, le roi
"d'Angleterre
et son Premier ministre."
Alors, la question qui se pose
et qu'on a vue
au moment
de la réforme des retraites,
c'est qu'il y a
cette tendance de verticalité
du pouvoir à occasionner
un grand mécontentement et laisse
apparaître le chef de l'Etat
comme s'il était le seul
et vrai détenteur
du pouvoir politique. Qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez,
Marie-Noëlle Lienemann ?
-C'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense,
disons qu'intrinsèquement,
dès l'origine,
la Ve République cristallise
une vision du pouvoir
qui ne me paraît
pas positive pour le pays.
Considérer que
l'élection d'un seul homme
avec l'essentiel des pouvoirs
et d'autant plus
avec une série de choses
comme le quinquennat
et la version du calendrier,
qui fait qu'on a une confusion
entre un président qui préside
et un gouvernement
qui gouverne de fait
une majorité. Je pense
que cette image-là est très néfaste,
parce qu'elle empêche
de produire l'idée
que le peuple français,
c'est dans sa collectivité,
dans sa complémentarité,
dans la capacité de décision
collective qu'il doit trouver
ses choix, ses orientations
et ses voies d'avenir.
-On déclinera
les différents aspects.
-Ca a aussi d'autres impacts
dans d'autres domaines.
L'idée
du chef d'entreprise tout-puissant,
que les corps intermédiaires
ont peu d'importance,
que le collectif est
secondaire par rapport
à la délégation
de pouvoir à un homme,
ça nous affaiblit collectivement
dans notre sens des responsabilités
et dans nos capacités
à décider ensemble.
-Vous êtes d'accord pour dire
que cette verticalité
du pouvoir obère
en quelque sorte la dimension
démocratique du pouvoir ?
Dominique Reynié.
-Je partage assez largement
ce que vient de dire
Mme Marie-Noëlle Lienemann.
J'avais envie de dire, au fond,
la verticalité du pouvoir,
c'est pas fait pour être exercé
en haut, si je puis dire.
Il y a bien sûr une fonctionnalité
à cette élection du chef de l'Etat,
à cette forme d'autorité.
Elle peut être d'une grande
nécessité, mais ça suppose
d'en faire un usage
plutôt exceptionnel,
de grands moments d'arbitrage
et d'orientation du pays.
Et, je vais m'en tenir là
pour ne pas
prendre trop de temps,
et en revanche,
et là, je suis encore une fois
d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit,
l'organisation du partage
dans la société, il est clair que
les collectivités locales n'ont
pas suffisamment de responsabilités,
que la décision publique
n'est pas partagée
avec suffisamment
de corps intermédiaires,
y compris
d'ailleurs le monde associatif
et le monde des entreprises.
Il y a tout un système
de coopération, qui est
à l'abandon, inhibé,
qui apporterait beaucoup au pays.
-Bon, oui,
Dominique Rousseau.
-Je serais peut-être un peu plus
nuancé. Un peu plus nuancé parce que
je pense que ce que vous avez décrit
ou la citation de Jean-Louis
Bourlanges
se réfère davantage
à la pratique politique
de la Ve République qu'au texte
de la Constitution de 1958.
Si on lit le texte de 1958,
le chef de l'Etat n'est pas
Premier ministre.
Il est chef de l'Etat. Et vous avez
le discours de Michel Debré
du 27 août 1958 au Conseil d'Etat,
qui explique bien que le président
de la République n'a pas de pouvoir
de décision,
il a un pouvoir de solliciter
d'autres pouvoirs.
-Là, vous êtes
dans la Constitution.
Est-ce que vous
n'avez pas été choqué
que, sur la réforme des retraites,
l'homme visé n'était que Macron,
c'est-à-dire
le président de la République,
et non pas tout le
gouvernement qui est incriminé ?
-Parce que depuis 1958 et pour des
raisons à la fois historiques,
la guerre d'Algérie et,
à la fin de la guerre d'Algérie,
la dissolution de 1962
qui donne une majorité
au parti gaulliste,
il y a eu ce que certains
appellent une dérive,
d'autres appellent ça
une violation du texte même
de la Constitution, qui fait que,
que ce soit Emmanuel Macron,
Nicolas Sarkozy,
Giscard d'Estaing, souvenez-vous
de Giscard d'Estaing en 1969
dénonçant l'exercice
solitaire du pouvoir.
Si vous voulez, c'est pas
une spécificité d'Emmanuel Macron
que toute la grogne,
la colère ou la contestation
se porte sur le président
de la République.
-Olivier Passelecq,
c'est justement là-dessus
qu'il faut préciser les choses.
La Constitution
de la Ve République avait
un caractère bâtard,
ce mot est de l'ancien président
Georges Pompidou,
pour exprimer la dimension hybride
de la Constitution de 58
qui, rappelons-le,
dans son article 3,
mettait au même niveau
la démocratie représentative,
c'est-à-dire les élections
législatives, et une forme
de démocratie directe
avec le référendum. Le déséquilibre
aujourd'hui est patent,
puisque le recours au référendum
est quasi obsolète.
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Oui, l'article 3
de la Constitution l'énonce bien.
"La souveraineté nationale
appartient au peuple
"qui l'exerce par ses représentants
et par le référendum."
Effectivement, cette Constitution
est fondée sur 2 piliers :
la démocratie représentative,
la démocratie directe.
Mais, malheureusement, le référendum
est tombé quasi en désuétude.
Il n'y en a eu que 9
depuis 65 ans,
4 par le général de Gaulle.
Ensuite, ça a été un peu dévoyé.
2 référendums importants, qui ont eu
beaucoup de tenue, qui ont donné
lieu à des débats de grande qualité,
sur Maastricht
et sur la constitution européenne,
qu'on a contournés
après par évidemment le vote
d'autres dispositions.
Je veux dire très rapidement
une conviction que j'ai,
qui est très profonde.
C'est que ce ne sont pas
les institutions
qu'il faut remettre en cause,
mais ceux qui s'en servent.
Et ceux qui s'en servent
en ce moment, ils s'en servent mal.
Et je pense qu'ils ont accru
cet exercice solitaire
du pouvoir, parce que finalement
le président de la République
aujourd'hui apparaît
comme très isolé.
Et précisément,
tout donc converge vers lui.
Il prétendait être Jupiter,
dieu des dieux, maître de la foudre,
mais maintenant c'est le tonnerre
qui lui tombe sur la tête.
-Alors, justement, précisons
à ce sujet la chose.
Si la pratique
référendaire est
tombée en désuétude,
à votre avis, c'est parce
que les différents présidents
de la République
qui n'en ont pas fait usage
craignaient d'être désavoués.
Dominique Reynié.
-Je ferais une remarque,
d'abord pour dire
que c'est très convergent
dans ce que nous disons,
même si chacun a le soin
de se distinguer un peu,
en réalité,
c'est très convergent sur le fond,
il y a un problème d'usage.
Et si on pense à l'usage,
il faut l'inscrire dans l'histoire.
Il me semble, c'est tout à fait
contestable bien sûr
ce que je vais dire,
mais il me semble
que nous entrons dans une époque,
ça fait un moment,
maintenant on sait que c'est sûr, où
il va falloir prendre des décisions
beaucoup plus compliquées
que celles que nous prenions
jusqu'à présent.
Si je fais référence à la situation
budgétaire, au déficit, etc.
C'est un argument
qui peut être reçu.
Je ne vois pas
dans ce contexte
quelle décision pourrait être prise
avec l'assentiment
du souverain
dans le cadre du référendum.
Les grandes décisions que nous
devrons prendre sont désagréables.
Elles ne passeront pas
si nous les adoptons par référendum.
Ca n'est pas pour ça
que la décision n'est pas nécessaire
ou mauvaise.
Au fond, le référendum,
c'était bien pour les époques
de croissance forte, de démographie
très favorable
et de redistribution programmatique
quasiment universelle, même
si les partis tardent à se caler
sur ce nouvel agenda historique.
Et maintenant, et d'ailleurs, c'est
cette remarque
que je ferais sur le débat de fond,
je ne sais pas quelle institution,
quel agencement, quelle république,
VIe, VIIe, VIIIe ou Xe,
nous permettrait
de faire adopter par le parlement
et encore moins par la population
une telle réforme.
-Oui, mais alors, justement...
-...l'émeute.
-Donc inventons de l'argent.
-Ecoutez,
on va essayer de vous départager
si je puis dire.
Si le référendum
ne peut pas être initié
par un président
de la République aujourd'hui,
on a ce référendum
d'initiative partagée
qui apparaît
comme un ersatz politique
de substitution. Ca vous convainc,
ça, Dominique Rousseau ?
Puisque le président
ne veut pas s'exposer,
c'est comme s'il y avait
un transfert
de responsabilité vers l'hypothèse
de 5 millions quasiment
d'électeurs.
-Il y a un problème particulier
de la France
à l'égard du référendum.
C'est le référendum
qu'a instauré la République,
mais c'est aussi le référendum
qui a fait tomber la République.
Et donc la France a
une culture du référendum
qui est plus plébiscitaire
et par conséquent, il y a
une espèce de recul, de distance,
de méfiance à l'égard
de la pratique référendaire.
On l'a vu en 1946,
on l'a vu en 2005.
Donc il y a une réserve à l'égard
de la pratique référendaire.
A propos du référendum
d'initiative partagée,
lorsque vous discutez avec ceux
qui l'ont établi
lors de la commission Balladur,
ils l'ont organisé
pour que ça ne marche
jamais. Ils le disent,
ils l'avouent.
C'est si compliqué...
-C'est une sucette
qui a été donnée au peuple ?
-Il a fallu faire
une concession, montrer
qu'on ouvrait, qu'on élargissait
le champ du référendum.
Alors, on l'a élargi,
comment dire, textuellement,
c'est-à-dire on a permis
qu'il y ait un référendum
sur d'autres questions
que les questions
institutionnelles, vous avez
bien dit référendum d'initiative
partagée.
A qui on donne la clé ?
On donne la clé aux parlementaires,
parce que c'est eux
qui l'ouvrent, il faut
qu'un cinquième signe,
et ceux qui peuvent le fermer,
parce que même
avec 4,9 millions de signatures,
ils peuvent empêcher le référendum
en examinant la proposition.
Donc initiative partagée...
Initiative
parlementaire en réalité.
-Constitutionnellement,
il y a pas un vice de forme ?
Des électeurs proposent
quelque chose
qui peut être retoqué
par l'Assemblée.
-Ce sont les parlementaires
qui proposent.
-Marie-Noëlle Lienemann.
-C'est complètement bidon, ce RIP.
Vous avez raison,
ça a été construit
pour donner l'illusion.
Il y a rien de pire
que des institutions
qui donnent des illusions.
Il faut que ce soit clair.
Moi, je pense
que, dans la période où nous sommes,
ça n'est pas vrai qu'en France,
mais particulièrement en France,
il y a un problème
de capacité pour le peuple
de pouvoir se faire entendre
et que l'équilibre...
-Mais vous êtes sénatrice,
vous représentez le peuple.
-Mais attendez,
l'équilibre des pouvoirs, justement
de ce point de vue de la Ve,
était intéressant,
c'est qu'il y a la représentation
et par moments
la nécessité du référendum,
le peuple souverain qui discute.
Si on avait voté
le traité constitutionnel
au parlement,
il aurait été mais massivement
approuvé, le traité de la
Constitution européenne, massivement
approuvé, alors qu'il a été
fortement contesté
par le peuple français.
Vous ne pouvez pas durablement
installer un système
où s'accroissent les différences
de points de vue. Pour ma part,
je pense que le champ référendaire
doit être repensé
dans nos institutions.
Bien sûr à l'initiative
du président de la République.
Il faut ouvrir un champ référendaire
à l'initiative
du parlement lui-même,
qui peut se sentir divisé,
pas suffisamment conforté dans
son point de vue et doit pouvoir
saisir le peuple. Et l'initiative
populaire ou citoyenne
et pas partagée.
La vraie question, c'est le champ
référendaire.
Jusqu'où on l'ouvre dans chacun
des domaines ? Par exemple,
je ne trouverais pas
sain qu'on puisse ouvrir
le champ référendaire
sur les droits fondamentaux.
-Mais qui en déciderait ?
-Si vous décidez...
-C'est la Constitution ?
C'est les sages ?
-La Constitution
définirait le champ référendaire
ouvert à chacune des...
-C'est la Constitution.
-Est-ce que l'immigration ferait
partie du champ référendaire ?
-C'est une bonne question.
Pour ma part, je pense...
Ca, ça fait partie des débats
quand on fait
une nouvelle constitution.
Pour ma part, je pense que,
quand ça s'attaque aux droits
fondements, par exemple, interdit
d'avoir des minarets ou des mosquées
en France, par exemple.
Ca, ça me permettrait pas
pouvoir être mis
en référendum, parce qu'on s'attaque
au socle des droits fondamentaux.
-Vous mettriez
l'immigration dedans ?
-J'ai pas une folle envie d'avoir
un débat sur l'immigration.
-Le peuple décide.
-J'allais le dire.
D'un autre côté, il n'y a rien
dans nos textes fondamentaux
si ce n'est le respect des droits
de l'homme et le droit d'asile,
qui sont incontestables. Je ne suis
pas pour le fermer à l'avance.
-C'est là, le problème.
-Dominique Rousseau.
-Le problème
du référendum. Je me souviens
qu'en 1984, je crois, le président
Mitterrand voulait ouvrir
la possibilité du référendum
aux problèmes de société.
-Référendum sur le référendum.
-Ca avait été retoqué par le Sénat
à l'époque notamment. Mais moi,
j'ai beaucoup de réticence à l'égard
du référendum. Et d'une certaine
manière, ce que vous venez de dire
montre qu'il y a des réticences.
On dit oui, OK sur les référendums,
mais pas sur toutes les questions.
Ou le peuple est souverain
ou il ne l'est pas.
Si le peuple est souverain,
à ce moment-là,
on le laisse se prononcer sur tout.
Le peuple peut se prononcer par
référendum et décider de remettre
en cause...
-On dit que, par exemple,
sur la peine de mort,
un référendum serait pas passé.
-C'est...
-Je ne suis pas sûre.
J'en ai discuté
avec François Mitterrand.
-C'est bien pour ça que je vous dis
que la question du référendum
est peut-être
un faux instrument de la démocratie
et un vrai instrument du populisme.
-Maastricht, il y a eu un vote.
-Pourquoi Maastricht,
c'est différent,
parce qu'il y a eu d'abord
un vrai débat.
-Eh ben voilà.
-Qui a conduit au référendum.
Je suis contre les référendums secs.
Or dans notre société d'aujourd'hui,
avec les réseaux sociaux,
avec les fake news,
avec tout ce qu'on voit,
il me semble difficile
d'organiser un référendum
quel que soit le domaine
à partir d'un débat sérieux,
rationnel
et qui ne soit pas pollué...
-Laissez-moi vous poser
une question de droit, Olivier
Passelecq. A votre avis,
sur cette question du référendum,
telle que la proposition
vient d'être énoncée
par Mme Lienemann,
à savoir qu'il n'émanerait pas
du président de la République,
mais qu'il émanerait
du parlement, la proposition
viendrait du parlement,
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
une double signature, par exemple,
sur la question du référendum ?
Est-ce que, constitutionnellement,
ça peut se faire ?
-Bon, très vite,
d'abord, le référendum
d'initiative parlementaire
existe dans l'article 11. Ca peut
être une proposition du parlement.
Je vais essayer
de faire une proposition,
parce que je savais
que Dominique Rousseau n'était pas
favorable au référendum,
je connais ses positions.
Moi, j'y suis
beaucoup plus favorable.
Donc on pourrait soit adopter
un vrai référendum
d'initiative citoyenne,
réclamé à cor et à cri
par les gilets jaunes,
le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne.
C'est bien quelque chose qui venait
bien vraiment du peuple.
Donc on pourrait
faire un vrai référendum
d'initiative citoyenne,
comme en Italie,
pour abroger une loi
ou pour adopter une loi
avec 500 000 électeurs.
C'est une 1re possibilité.
-Electeurs
ou signataires ?
-Electeurs. Electeurs.
Sinon on peut également revoir
ce fameux référendum
d'initiative partagée,
qui d'ailleurs était,
avant le comité Balladur,
prévu dès le comité Vedel.
A ce moment-là, il faudrait,
je crois, raccourcir les délais.
C'est-à-dire que ça dure pas
18 mois, mais par exemple
beaucoup moins.
Qu'on laisse, je crois,
un cinquième des parlementaires.
Mais qu'on abaisse précisément
là aussi peut-être à 500 000
ou 1 million le nombre
d'électeurs qui doivent soutenir
la proposition.
Et à ce moment-là,
réduire les délais, pas 9 mois,
c'est beaucoup trop long. Il faut
laisser ça 6 mois. Et surtout,
éviter ce qui est actuellement
dans la Constitution,
c'est que si jamais le parlement
s'en empare, il n'est pas obligé
d'ailleurs de se prononcer,
alors, c'est fini,
on n'en parle plus !
Donc c'est une usine à gaz
et je dirais même, c'est
une tromperie. C'est une tromperie.
-Dominique Reynié,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire,
puisqu'il n'y a pas
de bon référendum ?
-Moi, au fond,
je vous ai dit
mon sentiment principal.
Je crois que l'époque
est au référendum
par l'évolution de la société
et ce qui a été dit notamment
sur sa politisation conflictuelle
par les réseaux sociaux,
une espèce de besoin que l'on sent,
je ne sais pas exactement
la profondeur
du besoin, mais il est
très perceptible dans une partie
de la société politique française.
C'est peut-être 4, 5 millions,
10 millions,
pas 49 millions d'électeurs,
mais c'est beaucoup. Il y a
cette demande. Et par ailleurs,
je crois que soit les questions
qui seraient posées
à l'initiative du peuple
embarrasseraient beaucoup de monde,
y compris les personnes favorables
au référendum,
soit sur des grandes décisions
à prendre qui seraient
difficiles, le peuple s'y opposerait
par référendum,
alors que ce serait par hypothèse
une décision nécessaire.
Il existe des décisions nécessaires,
parfois elles sont impopulaires.
-Je comprends votre raisonnement.
Prenons les retraites.
On peut se fixer comme objectif
que nos comptes de retraite
soient équilibrés.
Ca, je veux dire, j'espère que les
trois quarts ou les neuf dixièmes
des gens pensent qu'il faut
que le système soit équilibré.
Nous faire croire qu'il y a
qu'une seule réforme possible,
je ne dis pas
que les autres seraient favorables,
mais quand on dit c'est défavorable,
ça fait mal,
mais ça fait mal à qui ?
Et lesquels ?
Et comment on arbitre ?
-C'était
dans le programme
politique du candidat.
-Attendez,
je veux dire
que le référendum lui-même,
il peut très bien,
même pour des décisions délicates
être pris parce que
on aura trouvé
des solutions qui apparaîtront
comme plus justes, plus équitables.
-On a 160 milliards
de déficit, c'est énorme.
Il va sans doute falloir
prendre une série de décisions
objectivement nécessaires
et je crois, hélas,
impopulaires. Là, je vois pas
comment on peut faire rentrer
le référendum dans un jeu pareil.
-Est-ce que durablement,
on peut multiplier
les décisions impopulaires ?
-On ne l'a pas fait,
il va falloir le faire.
-Oui. Dominique Rousseau.
-Si on fait un référendum,
alors, vous allez dire
que je suis embêtant
en tant que juriste,
mais le peuple qui se prononce,
est-ce que c'est le souverain
ou le corps législatif ?
Il y a plusieurs
peuples, le peuple qui s'exprime,
qui va voter une loi,
sur l'immigration, sur la peine
de mort. Est-ce le peuple
en tant que souverain
ou en tant que législateur ?
Si c'est le peuple en tant
que législateur, on peut
envisager l'hypothèse que le vote
qui sortirait du référendum,
la loi qui sortirait, pourrait être
soumis au contrôle
du Conseil constitutionnel.
Imaginez que le peuple vote
pour le rétablissement
de la peine de mort,
le Conseil constitutionnel
pourrait censurer la loi
adoptée par le peuple,
parce que ce n'est pas le souverain
qui se serait prononcé,
mais le corps législatif
dans la personne du législateur.
Il y a deux peuples, le souverain
et le législateur et si...
-Oui, mais
ils se confondent
en période de violences
sociales.
-Et non.
Ils se confondent pas.
-Si la question est considérée
comme anticonstitutionnelle,
parce qu'une fois votée,
elle serait anticonstitutionnelle,
c'est en amont.
-On peut le faire en amont.
-C'est mieux.
-Et aussi en aval.
-Il y a des fois des pratiques
qui font jurisprudence.
Prenons par exemple la période
de cohabitation à l'époque
du président Mitterrand, vous étiez
ministre, Marie-Noëlle Lienemann.
Le domaine
de la défense et de la politique
extérieure, domaine réservé,
ça n'existe nulle part
dans la Constitution.
-Nulle part.
-Ne faudrait-il pas parlementariser
cette chose-là ? Olivier Passelecq.
C'est une pratique finalement,
j'allais dire,
extraconstitutionnelle,
et pourtant, tous les présidents
l'ont adoptée après,
parce que c'était
plus pratique pour eux.
-Dans ma conception, le référendum
n'est pas utilisé quotidiennement
pour tout et n'importe quoi,
pour uniquement
des vraies questions.
La réforme des retraites,
on comprend pourquoi
le président Macron ne l'a pas
utilisé. Il savait
que le vote serait négatif.
Sinon, moi, ce que je voulais
dire, très vite, c'est que
non seulement la Constitution
est hybride,
mais le régime de la Ve République
est à géométrie variable.
Il peut être beaucoup plus
équilibré qu'il n'est actuellement.
C'est la cohabitation.
C'est-à-dire que le président
se trouve confronté à une majorité
parlementaire opposée.
Ca s'est produit à trois reprises.
Et là, alors, on retrouve
l'essence même de la Constitution
et du régime, qui est
parlementaire. C'est un vrai régime
parlementaire, la Ve République,
pas besoin d'une révolution
pour le rappeler.
Un, exécutif bicéphale,
oui. Droit de dissolution, oui.
Responsabilité du gouvernement
devant le parlement, oui.
C'est un régime parlementaire.
D'ailleurs,
ça plaît plutôt à l'opinion.
L'opinion aime
ce rééquilibrage du pouvoir.
Donc la cohabitation permet
de reparlementariser le régime.
-Et ça, c'est pas
la IVe République ?
-Non, parce qu'on a
le parlementarisme rationalisé.
Malheureusement, je vais
dire quelque chose d'horrible,
mais on a plutôt assisté
à un parlementarisme brutalisé.
-Vous êtes d'accord, Dominique
Reynié, sur ce retour
au parlementarisme qui s'exerce
en période de cohabitation,
mais pas en période
de pleins pouvoirs ?
-Pas en période de pleins pouvoirs
ni malheureusement dans une période
où la majorité est relative et où
nous avons tous honnêtement espéré
il y a un an que nous allions
faire une expérience
étonnante en France, mais heureuse,
d'un parlementarisme
raisonnable, construit.
-Oui.
-C'est un charivari permanent.
-Si on regarde...
-J'ai une question
pour vous.
Si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé dans notre passé récent,
qu'il s'agisse de la CSG ou même
de la Constitution, ça a été voté
sans majorité absolue.
-Oui.
-Et donc ça veut dire
que la Ve République est
assez souple pour permettre,
y compris dans des périodes
de cohabitation ou des périodes
où il n'y a pas de majorité
de faire fonctionner la politique.
-Oui,
mais justement, moi,
je pense que la vraie question,
c'est est-ce que
le Premier ministre procède
de la nomination du président
ou est-ce qu'il est issu
du parlement, d'un accord
majoritaire au parlement ?
Parce que ça change
d'une certaine façon tout.
Dans la mesure où, premièrement,
c'est sûr que si le président a
la majorité à 100 %...
-Il fait ce qu'il veut.
-La chambre
bleu horizon,
ils font ce qu'ils veulent
d'un côté comme de l'autre.
-C'est pas du parlementarisme.
-Voilà, mais par contre,
pourquoi je suis pour que le Premier
ministre soit issu du parlement ?
J'aime pas toujours ce que font
les Allemands, mais il y a un truc
sur lequel je trouve qu'ils ont
plutôt raison, en début de mandat,
il y a un accord majoritaire
des composantes du parlement,
qui vont mettre en oeuvre
des politiques qui sont évidemment
des compromis.
S'il faut faire
les réformes des retraites, on va
ponctionner les grosses entreprises.
Vous voyez,
il y a un compromis global.
Or nous faisons en permanence
l'économie de cela.
-Dominique Rousseau,
est-ce que vous pensez
que cette solution à l'allemande
était possible après la réélection
d'Emmanuel Macron ?
Comment aurait-il
pu constituer
cette coalition
en quelque sorte majoritaire ?
Avec le RN d'un côté,
les Insoumis de l'autre, les LR
qui étaient sur une autre position,
c'était introuvable.
-C'est ce qu'a dit Dominique Reynié.
Il y avait la possibilité de passer
à un parlementarisme raisonnable,
à un apprentissage du compromis,
de la conciliation,
ce que font les Allemands.
Vous avez le SPD,
les libéraux, je crois,
et les écolos
qui ont mis 6 mois...
-Mais le Bundestag n'est pas
l'Assemblée nationale.
-Nous, on a
une culture bonapartiste, jacobine,
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que ce soit
le chef qui détermine
le programme
et les autres se mettent derrière
sans concession.
Le problème des retraites, c'est que
le président de la République
a voulu que sa réforme
soit celle du gouvernement.
S'il avait laissé le gouvernement,
excusez-moi,
articles 20 et 21, déterminer
la politique du pays,
le Premier ministre
aurait pu discuter
avec les groupes parlementaires
et trouver
un consensus sur un programme
de réforme...
-C'est ce qui s'est passé.
-Non, puisqu'Emmanuel
Macron a dit, c'est ma réforme
qui va passer.
C'est ma réforme qui va passer,
débrouillez-vous, Elisabeth Borne,
pour la faire passer au parlement.
Si on était
dans un régime parlementaire,
le président de la République
aurait laissé la Première ministre
essayer de trouver un compromis
avec les différents groupes
sur la question de la réforme.
Mais là, on a été bloqués,
comme ça venait du président
le LR ne pouvait pas dire
OK, j'y vais.
Le RN ne pouvait pas. Etc. Etc.
Donc on a eu un parlementarisme,
on a eu une possibilité
de parlementarisme raisonnable
bloquée
par le président de la République.
-Vous avez vu la citation
d'Emmanuel Macron : "Je veux graver
"la liberté des femmes de recourir
à l'IVG dans la Constitution."
Alors, il n'y a pas
que l'IVG. On prête
au président de la République
différentes modifications.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que, sur la réforme électorale,
par exemple,
moins de parlementaires,
ça peut vous concerner
au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée nationale,
l'institution de la proportionnelle,
intégrale ou plus substantielle
qu'elle ne l'a été,
le vote obligatoire,
le quinquennat,
deux questions à propos
de tous ces changements.
Relèvent-ils
de la Constitution ?
Qu'est-ce qui relève
de la Constitution ? Qu'est-ce
qui relève d'une loi ordinaire ?
Qu'est-il opportun
de faire et de raisonnable ?
Qui veut commencer ?
-Je peux tout de suite répondre,
parce que j'allais le dire.
Tout ce qui concerne
le système électoral
pour les élections des députés,
c'est la loi ordinaire.
C'est même pas une loi organique
pour le système électoral.
Le seul système électoral
qui est dans la Constitution,
c'est pour le président
de la République.
Pour changer
le mode d'élection des députés,
une loi ordinaire suffit.
Proportionnelle, c'est une question,
il faut qu'on en débatte.
Mais je pense que,
parmi toutes les propositions,
si j'ai pas l'occasion
de le redire,
j'en ai une pour aller dans le sens
d'une reparlementarisation.
Ca a l'air de rien,
c'est un peu aussi
une bombe, mais je pense
qu'il faut supprimer l'article 19.
C'est-à-dire désormais,
tous les pouvoirs du président,
sont contresignés.
Alors là, ça aura un effet
très important, parce que le pouvoir
passe progressivement de celui
qui signe à celui qui contresigne,
en laissant bien sûr
à son rôle principal, l'article 5,
pour le président
de la République, d'être
un arbitre, d'en redevenir un.
Et comme l'a dit
Dominique Rousseau qu'enfin,
l'article 20, "le gouvernement
détermine et conduit
"la politique de la nation",
qui est donc respecté
en cohabitation,
eh bien, devienne la règle
et que le président
reprenne de la hauteur
et cesse effectivement une sorte
de monarque absolu de droit,
je dirais pas divin bien sûr, mais
de droit constitutionnel.
-Dominique Reynié,
on a étendu les choses.
Donc qu'est-il opportun
de faire et est-ce qu'on peut,
j'allais dire,
diluer le pouvoir présidentiel
en faisant contresigner
toutes les nominations
par exemple ?
-Toutes. Ca existe déjà, ça.
Il est pas dispensé
de contreseing, l'article 13.
-C'est une idée, je pense,
très riche, qui serait féconde,
mais je voulais répondre
à votre question
que nous avons vue à l'écran,
la citation du président Macron.
-L'IVG.
-Moi, je suis très inquiet
de cette évolution
du rapport à la Constitution,
c'est-à-dire une évolution
qui consiste à vouloir inscrire
dans la loi fondamentale des
décisions qui ont été prises déjà,
qui ne sont absolument pas menacées
en France et au motif
qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose ailleurs.
-Aux Etats-Unis.
-C'est très inquiétant. Ca l'est
d'autant plus que chaque président,
chaque candidat même maintenant
aura un objet de révision
à présenter dans son programme.
Cela devient un objet politique
comme un autre.
Alors, évidemment,
inutile d'imaginer ce que ça crée
comme précédent.
Rien n'empêchera une personne élue
plus tard à l'Elysée de défaire
ce que les autres
croyaient consolider
en le faisant. Et je terminerai
en faisant une remarque, on dit,
la Ve, elle marche
pas toujours, etc.
Mais combien de révisions
l'ont abîmée ?
Combien de décisions ont été prises
sans en mesurer réellement
les conséquences possibles ?
Je pense au quinquennat,
à l'inversion
du calendrier électoral,
je pense aussi à l'impossibilité
de faire un 3e mandat consécutif.
Après tout, le peuple peut
en décider.
Aujourd'hui, c'est très compliqué
pour un président.
On le savait, mais c'est
très compliqué de gouverner
sans possibilité de se représenter.
C'est absolument indémêlable.
Et donc nous avons fait beaucoup
de révisions, qui étaient, moi,
je les ai vécues ainsi, présentées
comme dans l'air du temps,
quelque chose qui devait s'imposer
par le rythme du monde, du moment.
Et à la fin,
on a des résultats catastrophiques
et là, on est en train
d'en faire l'expérience amère.
Tout ce qui nous aurait été
bien utile comme pouvoirs,
par exemple, la cohabitation
si elle est vertueuse
et l'opinion l'approuve,
ça pourrait se produire
en cas de dissolution,
mais sinon ça ne se produit pas.
On n'était pas loin,
il n'y a pas de majorité,
même de loin, relative,
il n'y a rien.
-Une impasse politique.
-Le premier groupe,
si on veut globaliser, après Macron,
c'est 150 députés de gauche,
c'est pas une majorité,
donc on est impuissants.
Mais non plus la réélection
étant impossible, le président
chaque jour est plus faible.
Nous créons nous-mêmes
le dysfonctionnement d'une Ve
que nous voulons remplacer.
-Marie-Noëlle
Lienemann, je vais vous
provoquer un petit peu.
Finalement,
ce que proposent les Insoumis
aujourd'hui, je sais
que vous n'en faites pas partie,
vous êtes pas éloignée,
vous êtes à gauche
de la gauche.
-Ah oui, je suis à gauche.
Vraiment à gauche.
-C'est pas un reproche
que je vous fais, mais est-ce que
finalement ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui, en disant
les décisions de l'exécutif
ne sont pas
les décisions du peuple,
est-ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de revenir
à ce que disait André Laignel...
-Vous avez politiquement
tort...
-Vous avez juridiquement
tort, parce que politiquement
minoritaires.
-J'ai jamais
approuvé ça.
Je suis une vieille républicaine.
Je fais partie
de la gauche républicaine,
je crois aux institutions,
même si je veux les changer.
-Est-ce que
vous vous distinguez aujourd'hui
des revendications des Insoumis ?
Et parce que votre voix
porte, vous êtes considérée
comme étant à la gauche
de la gauche.
-S'il s'agit de redéfinir
le champ référendaire,
je pense qu'il faut élargir
le champ référendaire.
Et pour couper court à l'idée
qu'on n'a pas le temps de discuter,
qu'on vote sans avoir beaucoup
travaillé, on pourrait prendre
exemple sur la Suisse sur l'idée
de la journée référendaire.
C'est-à-dire qu'on sait à l'avance
qu'il y a une journée
où on fait les référendums
et qu'à ce moment-là, il y a
une préparation du débat politique
pour que ce soit pas
l'air du temps, à l'instant T, etc.
Bon ça,
premier point. Deuxièmement,
je crois beaucoup au parlement,
je suis totalement
contre les mandats révocatoires
et autres.
La révocation, c'est l'élection.
Je suis pour
qu'on renforce le parlement
et de ce point de vue,
je l'ai dit, la façon
dont le Premier ministre est choisi,
c'est-à-dire
par le vote du parlement et pas
par la désignation du président
me paraît essentielle.
Je suis aussi pour limiter
le champ de l'intervention
du président,
qui doit garder
une partie de recours et une partie
de grand arbitre,
et même, pour être franche,
une certaine présence à l'étranger.
Je pense que c'est quand même
assez bien accepté par les Français,
même si quand même
je suis effondrée de la faiblesse
des débats politiques
actuels au sein du parlement
sur la politique étrangère
de la France.
-C'est pareil sur le budget.
-La 3e chose
que je crois très importante,
c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire
des révisions constitutionnelles
tous les quarts d'heure.
Il y a des moments
de temps politique,
où il faut se reposer des questions
sur des choses, sur, par exemple,
les droits fondamentaux
inscrits dans la Constitution.
Et de ce point de vue,
je trouve que la question de l'IVG,
c'est pas seulement une question
d'opportunité parce qu'il y a
des risques. Je pense
qu'il y a toute une série de droits
qui ne sont plus suffisamment
inscrits dans la Constitution
comme des garanties durables.
Et je prends un exemple
qui n'est même pas d'actualité
aux yeux des gens.
C'est le droit au logement.
Vous avez dans la Constitution
le droit à la propriété.
Le droit au logement est considéré
comme de valeur constitutionnelle,
mais quand il y a un arbitrage
à faire entre un droit
constitutionnel et un droit
à valeur,
et notamment
quand il s'agit d'exproprier,
quand il s'agit
de réquisitionner.
Je peux vous assurer
que, dans toute une série
de jugements au jour le jour,
ça pèse. Il y a des moments,
il faut se dire quels sont
les droits constitutionnels,
par exemple, la garantie
de ses données personnelles,
et là, il faut
un travail de profondeur,
pendant quelques années,
pour redéfinir le champ des droits
fondamentaux garantis
par la Constitution.
-On pourrait constitutionnaliser
la protection
des données personnelles,
mais la puissance publique
est incapable de la faire respecter
sur les plateformes numériques
américaines et chinoises.
-Vous avez des tas de droits...
On fait quand même le RGPD.
-C'est rien du tout,
ça ne s'applique qu'aux Européens.
-C'est bien aussi le but
de savoir ce que la nation a décidé,
quelles sont ses missions
collectives de garantir des droits.
-Il peut pas sur le numérique.
-Il peut pas, il doit s'en donner
les moyens.
-Sur ce toilettage,
je vais vous passer la parole.
Sur ce toilettage qui est proposé,
Olivier Passelecq
et Dominique Rousseau.
-Un mot rapide, juridiquement,
les droits fondamentaux,
les libertés
les plus essentielles ne sont pas
inscrites dans la Constitution,
mais dans le bloc
de constitutionnalité.
Donc finalement,
ça n'ajoutera pas grand-chose
de rajouter l'IVG.
C'est ce que je voulais
dire, mais je pense que,
comme on avance dans le débat,
il faut que les téléspectateurs
soient conscients
que tout ce qu'on dira
a très peu de chances
d'être approuvé
dans les mois qui viennent.
Mais voilà, ce sont des pistes
pour l'avenir.
-Dominique Rousseau,
est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il serait plus juste
et pour calmer un peu,
j'allais dire, la fronde populaire,
de faire rentrer ces droits,
les sociétés évoluent,
l'IVG fait partie aujourd'hui
d'une évolution majeure,
comme d'autres réformes sociétales,
et au regard du côté pernicieux,
comme dirait l'économiste
Daniel Cohen,
du numérique, est-ce que
il n'y a pas à toiletter
la Constitution pour raffermir
ces droits fondamentaux ?
-Alors, toiletter,
on l'a dit,
elle a été beaucoup toilettée,
plus ou moins bien d'ailleurs,
depuis 1958.
On parle de la Ve
ou de la VIe République,
mais enfin, en 58, le président
était élu pour 7 ans,
maintenant, c'est 5 ans,
une fois renouvelable, il était élu
par un corps électoral, maintenant
par le suffrage universel.
En 58,
l'Assemblée nationale siégeait
en deux sessions de 6 mois,
de 3 mois,
maintenant c'est à l'année.
Il n'y avait pas de Conseil
constitutionnel, pas de QPC,
pas de contrôle a priori.
Autrement dit,
on parle de la Ve République,
mais...
-C'est un corps vivant quand même.
-Le cadre constitutionnel
a complètement changé.
Donc un toilettage supplémentaire
risquerait d'arriver à une espèce
de bricolage institutionnel,
ce qui fait qu'on ne sait plus
exactement ce que la Constitution
nous dit de nous-mêmes.
N'oubliez pas que la Constitution,
c'est pas simplement
un texte technique
qui répartit les compétences
entre président,
Premier ministre, parlement.
C'est aussi ce qui donne
une identité à une société.
C'est une sorte de miroir
dans lequel on se regarde.
-Sa carte d'identité.
-J'ai tel et tel droit.
Ce qui me frappe, ce qui m'intéresse
et évidemment ce qui m'interroge,
parce que je le prends aussi
comme interrogation, c'est
que tous les mouvements sociaux
à un moment donné demandent
à ce que leurs revendications soient
inscrites dans la Constitution.
Je suis content
en tant que constitutionnaliste.
Les gens qui défilent dans la rue
pour le respect de la biodiversité
voudraient que ça rentre
dans la Constitution.
Les femmes, faut que ça rentre
-On y est déjà,
j'espère.
-Pourquoi les mouvements
sociaux ont toujours
un débouché constitutionnel ?
Je préfère qu'ils aient
un débouché constitutionnel
qu'un débouché violent.
Ca me paraît
plus positif.
En ce sens, la Constitution
est ce qui donne son identité,
c'est le texte
dans lequel une société
se reconnaît. Il y a une phrase
de Benjamin Constant, qui me...
Comment dire ?
Qui anime ma réflexion
de constitutionnaliste,
et qui disait, de mémoire :
"Tant que les idées
et les institutions sont de niveau,
"les institutions subsistent.
"Mais quand les idées
et les institutions
"ne sont plus au même niveau,
à ce moment-là, dit-il,
"il y a une crise."
Et je pense que, pour terminer,
je pense que nous sommes
dans un moment
où les institutions
ne sont plus au niveau
des idées et que, par conséquent,
il faut modifier les institutions
pour les mettre au niveau. Alors,
les idées, disait Benjamin Constant,
on pourrait dire l'esprit du siècle
ou l'esprit du moment. Et l'esprit
du moment fait que les citoyens,
la société, à tort ou à raison,
la société demande à être associée
à la fabrication des lois.
Or vous n'avez pas
d'institution qui permet
aux citoyens d'être associés
à la fabrication.
-Il y a une question qui fâche
et à laquelle peut-être
je vais vous demander de trancher.
Aujourd'hui, dans ce qu'on appelle
la société multiculturelle,
il y a un délayage.
Par exemple, en ce qui concerne
la violence régalienne.
Est-ce qu'elle doit être
le monopole de la police ?
Parce que c'est contesté
aujourd'hui.
-Bah non !
-Non.
-C'est pas contesté. C'est contesté
parce qu'on ignore.
-Dans le débat politique français,
vous avez
pas aujourd'hui unanimité
pour considérer
que la violence régalienne...
-C'est un effondrement
de la culture politique.
-Vous considérez
que ce qui est proposé par
une partie de la classe politique
est un effondrement démocratique ?
-C'est une incompréhension
fondamentale
de ce qu'est le pouvoir...
Laissez-moi finir.
C'est un effondrement
de la définition, je dirais...
Alors, les gens parfois
pensent à Max Weber.
Max Weber est mort en 1920 et bien
des auteurs l'ont écrit avant lui.
Baudin et d'autres,
et bien avant encore.
Le pouvoir,
pour être souverain, il faut
qu'il ait la maîtrise du recours
légal à la violence.
Sinon il n'est pas
le pouvoir souverain.
S'il y a un pouvoir plus fort
par la violence, c'est là
que se trouvera l'Etat. C'est
une logique,
c'est même pas une invention,
mais un mécanisme logique.
Il est insensé de dire
qu'on pourrait avoir un système
dans lequel l'Etat n'aurait pas
le monopole de la violence légale.
-Je suis d'accord là-dessus,
mais la question, c'est est-ce
que la violence est proportionnée ?
-C'est autre chose.
-Le débat, actuellement,
je n'entends pas beaucoup,
il y a des anars,
des black blocs, etc.,
mais le gros
de la population française,
même quand elle conteste la police,
c'est vieux comme Hérode en France,
on n'aime pas spontanément
la police
et, en même temps, on considère
qu'on en a impérativement besoin.
Ce que je ressens
n'est pas du tout la contestation
de la violence légitime de l'Etat
quand il doit garantir
la sécurité des personnes
et l'intérêt général.
La vraie question,
c'est l'abusus,
c'est jusqu'où on provoque...
-Comment on mesure ça,
l'abusus ?
-Il y a des règles.
La violence doit être proportionnée.
Peut-être qu'il y a
des choses à réfléchir
sur faire la preuve qu'on a fait
de la prévention suffisante.
Il y a un débat politique à avoir.
-Quelle est la violence
proportionnée à des manifestants
qui incendient des policiers ?
-Je suis pour qu'ils trouvent
des moyens de les arrêter.
-Il faut y aller sacrément.
-Il y a d'autres pays
qui sont aujourd'hui confrontés
aux mêmes sujets qui ont
des stratégies de distanciation,
des stratégies policières
différentes. Ce débat est légitime.
-Et peut-être un discours public
moins compréhensif
à l'égard de la violence.
-Je veux bien que tout soit
de la faute de la gauche.
-Non, pas du tout.
On a historiquement en France un
rapport à la violence assez étrange.
-Olivier Passelecq.
-Je reste convaincue
qu'il faut...
-Pour venir au secours
d'Emile Malet, c'est vrai que
la France insoumise remet en cause
ce monopole de la violence légitime.
-Pas vraiment.
-Ah si. Et Mélenchon
règle des comptes.
On sait qu'il a eu
maille à partir avec la police,
on voit bien
que vraiment il veut s'opposer
de toute façon à la police,
d'où les slogans
"tout le monde déteste la police",
etc.
-En 68 déjà.
-Et "à bas la mauvaise république".
C'est plus récent.
-Attendez, il faut aussi
relativiser,
même si personnellement,
je suis pas du tout
dans ce genre-là, mais en mai 68,
"CRS SS", "à bas la police",
"personne n'aime la police",
je l'ai entendu.
-J'ai vécu ça.
-Est-ce que pour autant la société
française est devenue
plus antipolice qu'avant ?
-Non.
-Non, c'est pas la question.
-Et ça n'a pas remis en cause
le principe de la légitimité
de la police et de l'Etat
et de la justice de garantir
le monopole de la violence.
-Dominique Rousseau,
vous ne vous êtes pas exprimé
sur ce point.
-Je ne me suis pas exprimé
parce que je pense
que ce qui a été dit
me paraît juste. C'est normal
que l'Etat ait le monopole
de la violence légale, légitime,
et c'est également normal que
l'Etat fasse un usage proportionné
de la violence.
Que voulez-vous dire d'autre ?
-Voilà.
-C'est le bon sens même.
Et il suffit à la fois
que le ministre de l'Intérieur,
il faut aussi
que le parlement joue son rôle
dans le contrôle
éventuellement des abus
faits par la police.
-Et la discussion
sur la stratégie policière
qu'on a rarement.
-Les deux, pour moi, oui,
l'Etat doit avoir
et doit continuer à avoir
le monopole de la violence légitime,
mais en contrepartie,
il faut qu'il en fasse un usage
proportionné.
Que voulez-vous dire d'autre ?
-On va essayer
quand même de terminer
sur une note un peu plus positive.
Sur les réformes,
il y en a peut-être
une ou deux où il y a un consensus.
Pourquoi on peut pas
avancer dans ce domaine-là ?
Je pense par exemple
au cumul des mandats. On entend
de tous bords, à droite et à gauche,
considérer
qu'il faudrait rétablir le cumul
des mandats. Deuxième chose,
sur l'inversion
du calendrier des élections
entre législatives
et présidentielles, là aussi,
il semblerait
qu'il y ait une volonté
d'un côté comme de l'autre
de bouger.
Qu'est-ce qui est faisable ?
Qu'est-ce qui n'est pas faisable ?
Qu'est-ce qui serait opportun
aujourd'hui d'avancer
pour faire unité nationale ?
Vous avez 2 minutes chacun
et ça permet de conclure
notre émission.
Dominique Rousseau.
-Je reste partisan
du non-cumul des mandats.
Dans la mesure où un parlementaire
ne représente pas
sa circonscription,
il représente la nation.
Et que, par conséquent,
un parlementaire,
un parlementaire élu
à Marseille ne doit pas
défendre les intérêts de Marseille,
il doit défendre
les intérêts de la nation.
Et il faut qu'il y ait une
séparation entre ceux qui ont
à gérer les affaires locales ou
régionales et ceux qui ont à gérer
les affaires nationales.
Une des raisons
du déclin du parlement
tient précisément
au fait que les parlementaires sont
tellement imprégnés par le souci
de défendre les intérêts locaux
qu'ils oublient l'intérêt national.
De ce côté-là, moi,
je pense qu'on doit continuer.
-Et sur l'inversion de calendrier ?
-Ca, c'est de la chiquenaude,
c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez pas traiter
la question de l'inversion
du calendrier électoral sans traiter
la question,
un, de la durée du mandat,
deux, des pouvoirs...
-Et vous êtes
pour la durée du mandat,
un mandat, 7 ans, ou deux ?
-Je considère
que la durée du mandat importe peu.
Dans tous les pays où le président
est élu par le peuple,
je dis bien est élu par le peuple,
ce n'est pas le président
qui dirige,
mais le Premier ministre.
Par conséquent, il n'y a pas
un lien mécanique
entre élection populaire
et hyper présidentialisation.
-Donc il faut les distinguer ?
-Il faut les distinguer
et, si vous me demandez une réforme,
ce que je proposerais,
c'est que le président
de la République ne préside plus
le conseil des ministres,
que le conseil des ministres
se tienne à Matignon,
sous la présidence
du Premier ministre
et on retrouverait
le président dans une position
d'arbitre.
-Merci. Olivier Passelecq.
-Dominique Rousseau rejoint un peu
ce que je disais tout à l'heure.
Une vraie réforme révolutionnaire
serait de supprimer
les pouvoirs propres
du président de la République,
car tous les autres pouvoirs,
même ceux dits du domaine réservé,
diplomatie et défense,
sont des pouvoirs contresignés.
C'est la pratique
qui a fait que le président
a dominé les institutions.
C'est pas dans la Constitution.
La Constitution peut avoir
une application totalement
parlementaire,
et je suis heureux
de l'avoir entendu,
équivalente
à d'autres pays d'Europe,
où le président est élu
au suffrage universel
direct, mais où il n'exerce pas,
je le répète,
cette monarchie absolue
de droit constitutionnel.
-Merci. Sur ces deux points.
-On est d'accord sur l'idée
que l'important est de redonner
un Premier ministre et un parlement
qui aient réellement le pouvoir.
Je vais parler
d'un sujet peu évoqué.
-On a peu de temps.
Très peu de temps.
-Tout le monde se plaint que la loi,
c'est de la bureaucratie,
que l'Etat s'est bureaucratisé.
La nature de la loi et du règlement,
tel que défini dans nos traditions
législatives, bureaucratise l'Etat
et par ailleurs rend difficile
la prise en compte du réel
sur les différents territoires.
Et pousse à l'idée que la loi
doit s'adapter aux territoires.
Je pense que c'est une grave menace.
La loi doit rester unique
dans notre République,
mais il faut
que la loi soit plus structurée
en laissant davantage
de marge de manoeuvre
que le réglementaire
aujourd'hui corsète.
-Merci. Je sais pas si vous avez été
influencé par la personne
en face vous, Hannah Arendt,
qui disait que,
dans une société, quand la loi
se bureaucratise,
il y a danger pour la démocratie.
Dominique Reynié,
sur les deux points.
-Je terminerai rapidement
avec des remarques de politologue
à l'adresse
de mes collègues publicistes.
Ce qu'ils savent très bien et vous
le savez aussi, Madame la Sénatrice.
Quand on touche aux institutions,
même si c'est
un détail, les effets systémiques
sont souvent impressionnants.
Je donne deux exemples. Un premier
exemple, on peut revenir au cumul
des mandats si on veut rapprocher,
par exemple,
par hypothèse, les députés
des besoins plus locaux du peuple,
si on ne le fait pas, il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on fait
avec le mode de scrutin.
La proportionnelle,
par scrutin de liste,
elle éloigne beaucoup.
Et ma deuxième remarque est sur ce
qui a été évoqué par mes collègues,
que je trouve très intéressant,
sur ces réformes qui changeraient
le pouvoir du président
et vous étiez d'accord,
Madame la Sénatrice,
ça aurait un avantage énorme,
ça sélectionnerait peut-être
d'autres profils
pour l'élection présidentielle.
Ce serait très utile au pays
que nous ayons des profils.
Au fond, ceux
qui ne se sont jamais présentés,
qui n'y sont pas arrivés, c'était
des profils très différents
de ceux qui y sont arrivés.
Je pense à Rocard, à Balladur,
à Delors, à Barr.
Ce sont pas les mêmes profils
et c'est peut-être pas
une bonne chose
que nous ayons un système
qui, promettant la royauté,
sélectionne
des psychologies et des profils
qui sont pas ceux avec lesquelles
on peut faire compromis.
-On va terminer là-dessus.
-Belle conclusion.
-Je suis pas vraiment de votre avis.
-Merci, Madame. Merci.
Merci, Madame, merci,
Messieurs.
Il me reste à vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Je rappelle, Olivier Passelecq,
vous avez publié
avec Francis Hamon un ouvrage
sur le référendum en Europe.
Depuis, vous n'avez pas
changé d'idée.
-Non.
-Dominique Rousseau, "Six thèses
pour la démocratie continue",
chez Odile Jacob. C'est quoi,
cette démocratie
continue en deux mots ?
-C'est une démocratie
qui ne s'arrête pas
entre deux moments électoraux,
donc elle est continue,
et qui ne s'arrête pas
aux portes de l'entreprise,
qui ne s'arrête pas
aux portes de la famille,
mais une démocratie
dont les principes se diffusent
dans l'ensemble de la société
et ne restent pas
au niveau de l'Etat.
-Marie-Noëlle Lienemann, vous avez
publié il y a quelques années,
"Merci pour ce changement !"
Il s'agissait de quoi ?
-J'ai publié beaucoup de choses.
En général, je plaide
pour ce changement institutionnel.
Quand je regarde
l'exercice de la gauche au pouvoir,
même, par exemple, sous Jospin,
qui n'était pas président,
je vois les fragilités structurelles
du fait qu'il y ait pas besoin
d'un accord parlementaire
entre l'ensemble
des forces de la majorité
et qu'on soit ballotés en fonction
des événements, sans qu'il y ait
un accord politique d'ensemble
qui trouve son équilibre.
Et à un moment ou un autre,
les forces, le peuple
se décrochent des forces politiques
et il y a toujours des crises. On
finit toujours les fins de mandats
dans des mauvaises situations.
-Merci.
Alors, Dominique Reynié,
je rappelle qu'à Fondapol,
vous publiez
de nombreuses études
sur tous les sujets politiques
et que vous-même,
vous avez coordonné un ouvrage,
"Le XXIe siècle
du christianisme".
-Je n'ai pas changé d'avis.
Rires
-Voilà.
Vous n'avez pas changé d'avis.
Il me reste à vous remercier
d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
et, avant de nous quitter,
je vous soumets cette citation :
"Si l'on se lance dans un Meccano
bavard et déclamatoire
"décroché des réalités
"historiques,
"le retour à la IVe République
"deviendra effectif
et irrémédiable."
C'est une citation
d'Arnaud Teyssier.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA